laut dieser vorraumfrage könnten sich
79% der deutschen vorstellen mit e-fuels
zu fahren 60% würden das sogar einem
E-Auto vorziehen diese Kraftstoffe
könnten klimaneutral hergestellt werden
und wären nur ein wenig teurer als
herkömmlicher wow Rabatte Verbrenner aus
und Ladesäulen all das kostet Geld und
ist aufwendig warum denn der ganze
Zirkus für E-Autos oder gibt es mit der
Umfrage vielleicht ein Problem lass mich
nur so viel sagen das gibt es aber was
sind efuels überhaupt wie stellt man sie
her und wo versprechen sie vielleicht zu
viel genau darum geht es heute bei dr
Watson
[Musik]
fangen wir mal ganz vorne an
fuels sind synthetische Kraftstoffe die
aus Wasserstoff und CO2 hergestellt
werden dabei wird im Idealfall Strom aus
erneuerbaren Energien zur Herstellung
des Wasserstoffs eingesetzt der fertige
Kraftstoff kann dann ohne
verbrennermotoren umzurüsten getankt
werden man kann also CO2 aus der Luft zu
efuels verarbeiten und so theoretisch
klimaneutral mit Auto Schiff oder
Flugzeug unterwegs sein
[Applaus]
geniale Idee aber wie effizient sind
diese Kraftstoffe im Vergleich zu zum
Beispiel E-Autos schon im ersten Schritt
der Herstellung vom Wasserstoff gehen je
nach Methode bis zu 30% der Energie
verloren aber nicht nur dort sondern
auch beim Filtern des co2s der
Herstellung und dem Transport wird
Energie gebraucht am Ende enthält der
fertige Kraftstoff noch ungefähr 55% der
aufgewendeten Energie und das ist laut
Umweltbundesamt noch eine sehr
optimistische Schätzung für ein
Elektroauto entstehen hingegen nur etwa
6% Verluste von der Stromerzeugung bis
zur Batterie davon landet aber dann auch
unterschiedlich viel auf dem Asphalt bei
Verbrenner Motoren werden nur ungefähr
30% tatsächlich in Bewegungsenergie
umgesetzt erneut relativ optimistisch
E-Autos dagegen liegen bei um die 80%.
man kommt also mit der gleichen Menge
Energie 5 mal so weit wenn man Auto
fährt
lasst uns mal ein Szenario durchspielen
nehmen wir an morgen wäre jedes der 45
Millionen Autos in Deutschland ein
E-Auto unrealistisch ich weiß aber wie
viel zusätzlichen Strom bräuchten wir
dafür pro Jahr das
Bundesverkehrsministerium schätzt diesen
Bedarf auf etwa 100 Terawattstunden 18%
von unserem aktuellen Strombedarf wenn
wir alle Autos wiederum mit e-views
betanken wollen also denselben
Energiebedarf mal 5 und heißt das wir
würden den deutschen Strombedarf fast
verdoppeln je nach Schätzung manche
sagen sogar das ist mehr wäre und das
nur mit PKW alle anderen Fahrzeuge sind
da noch aus dem vorgelassen ach ja und
wenn wir das wirklich klimaneutral
machen wollen dann setzt das natürlich
Klima neutralen Strom voraus den wir
aber noch gar nicht haben in Deutschland
ist der Ausbau noch immer zu langsam und
auch in Europa sind wir von den 100%
noch ziemlich weit entfernt
der Strom hierzulande reicht also nicht
für e-fuels es gibt aber Regionen die
ein Vielfaches ihres eigenen
Strombedarfs produzieren könnten Chile
könnte zum Beispiel theoretisch mehr als
das
65-fache des eigenen Strombedarfs
herstellen wenn man e-fuels aus Regionen
wie Patagonien oder Marokko importiert
und es dort quasi unbegrenzt
erneuerbaren Strom gibt dann ist die
Effizienz doch letztlich egal oder das
Schlagen zumindest Befürworter von vor
in diesem Fall sind das zwei
mineralölverbände die davon profitieren
würden dass es weiterhin Verbrenner und
Tankstellen gibt sie fordern in dieser
Studie hier eine ganzheitliche
Betrachtung die sich nicht nur auf
technische Effizienz bezieht die Aussage
man muss auch einberechnen dass eine
Anlage am bestmöglichen Standort mehr
Strom produziert
aber ist der großflächige Import von
e-fuels überhaupt realistisch in
Patagonien hat Porsche gerade eine
Fabrik für e-fuels eröffnet in der 2026
550 Millionen Liter pro Jahr produziert
werden sollen das sind weniger als 1,5%
des deutschen jährlichen
Kraftstoffverbrauchs wird also knapp
wenn 60% der deutschen lieber mit
e-fuels als mit E-Autos fahren würden
und keine Sorge zu der Umfrage kommen
wir gleich noch auch der Import ist also
im großen Rahmen eher unrealistisch denn
bei diesem Berechnungen werden Wind und
Solaranlagen eingerechnet die einfach
noch nicht existieren und selbst wenn
die Anlagen da wären wäre der Export
erst sinnvoll wenn das Herkunftsland
selbst 100% grünen Strom verwendet Chili
tut das z.B noch nicht vorher sollten
dort keine euels hergestellt werden die
auf der anderen Seite der Welt dann
wieder verbrannt werden weil grüner
Strom knapp ist sollte er dort
eingesetzt werden wo er am meisten
Emissionen verhindert und das ist eben
nicht im Verbrennerauto sondern in
direkten Elektrifizierung hi hier ist
Jakob aus dem Produktionsteam hinter dr
Wats vielleicht kennt ihr mich schon aus
dem ein oder anderen Video oder von
Pager ich stelle euch heute mal den
Partner dieses Videos vor und das ist
klar genauso in effektiv wie efuels
waren ehrlich gesagt auch meine
Versicherung in der Vergangenheit ich
habe mir ehrlich nie viele Gedanken
gemacht in den letzten Monaten habe ich
dann aber versucht meine Finanzen etwas
zu optimieren und mehr zu sparen da man
die Inflation ja echt überall spürt
deshalb habe ich Clark einfach mal
ausprobiert über die Jahre haben sich
bei mir ein paar Versicherung
angesammelt aber irgendwie weiß man da
ja nie so genau was da jetzt wirklich
sinnvoll ist klar man kann sie einfach
gar nicht versichern und spart dann auch
Geld aber so ein paar Risiken sollte man
ja doch je nach Lebenssituation
abgesichert haben und darum kann sich
klagt dann für euch kümmern wenn man in
die App seine aktuellen Versicherung
überträgt bekommt man Vorschläge wo noch
gespart werden kann oder ob man
vielleicht noch was für seine
Altersvorsorge tun kann damit klagt dann
aktiv werden darf und dann zeichnet man
ein maklermaß hat und so darf klar dann
für euch neu Versicherung abschließen
natürlich nur wenn ihr das wollt falls
ihr schon einen Makler habt verliert er
aber sein Mandat das sollte man noch
wissen wenn bei euren Versicherungen
auch noch Optimierungsbedarf herrscht so
wie bei mir und die uns unterstützen
wollt dann nutzt gerne bei der
Registrierung den Code Watson wenn ihr
die App herunterladet oder klickt
einfach auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung oder sichert euch über
den QR-Code hier im Bild ab für die
ersten drei Versicherung die in die App
übertragen bekommt ihr jeweils ein 15 €
Gutschein für z.B den App Store
Cyberport oder Amazon so das war's auch
von mir zurück zum Video zurück zu
unseren
feststeht es wird schwierig sie in den
benötigten Mengen herzustellen und ob
sie tatsächlich was fürs Klima bringen
hängt vor allem vom Strom ab mit dem der
Wasserstoff produziert wird kommen wir
dann jetzt mal zu der Frage die
Verbraucher am Ende eigentlich am
meisten interessiert wie teuer wird der
Spaß die Schätzungen reichen von einem
bis sechs Euro pro Liter und ihr dachtet
10% Inflation wäre viel
tendenziell gehen Mineralöl oder
autoverbände dabei von sehr niedrigen
Preisen aus in diesem Szenarien werden
die fuels anfangs nur beigemischt und
der Anteil nach und nach erhöht das
bedeutet dass die Kosten aber eben auch
der versprochene klimanutzen nur langsam
zunehmen ein deutsches Unternehmen will
schon dieses Jahr eine Zapfsäule für
e-fuels eröffnen produziert wird der
Sprit in Belgien zum Teil auch mit
Atomstrom wurde uns auf Nachfrage
erklärt ein Liter soll dort 5 bis 6 €
Kosten das könnte zu teuer sein finden
Befürworter und fordern daher
Subventionen und Steuervorteile um
efuels wettbewerbsfähig zu machen
allerdings werden nach einer Schätzung
mindestens 1,50 € Unterstützung pro
Liter benötigt um in diesem Fall diese
überhaupt wirtschaftlich herzustellen
selbst bei einer sagen wir mal
vorsichtig ausgedrückt unrealistischen
Subventionierung von 3 Euro pro Liter
würde der Anteil von efuels
voraussichtlich nur langsam steigen die
Schätzung geht davon aus dass fossile
Kraftstoffe bis 2050 teurer und ifuels
immer günstiger werden aber da der
Hauptfaktor der benötigte Strom ist ist
der Preis stark abhängig von der
Stromquelle mit deutschem offshorestrom
wären sie auch 50 noch fast doppelt so
teuer wie fossile Treibstoffe wenn bis
dahin der Import aus Island Chile oder
Marokko funktioniert könnten sie 20150
preistechnisch mit fossilen Benzin
mithalten 2030 gibt es aber immer noch
große Unterschiede viele hoffen auch auf
used aus Überschussstrom der nicht
eingespeist werden kann für einen
wirtschaftlichen Betrieb brauchen die
Anlagen aber günstigen erneuerbaren
Strom für mindestens 3000 er aber 4000
oder mehr Volllaststunden im Jahr mit
reinem Überschussstrom ist das nicht
machbar übrigens Quellen zu allen
unseren Aussagen und unseren Recherchen
findet ihr wie immer unten in der
Videobeschreibung
[Musik]
beim Individualverkehr ist das also
alles nicht ganz so easy aber in einem
Bereich sind e-fuels tatsächlich eine
vielversprechende Option bei Flugzeugen
und Schiffen ist es deutlich schwieriger
Strom direkt zu nutzen weil die
Batterien zu groß und zu schwer wären
und bis wasserstofftechnologien weit
genug sind dauert das vermutlich zu lang
zumindest wenn sie zur Reduzierung von
Treibhausgasen beitragen sollen außerdem
ist Wasserstoff im Vergleich zu efuels
schwierig zu transportieren und zu
lagern mit efuels ließe sich dieses
Problem also zumindest ansatzweise lösen
gucken uns die Luftfahrt noch mal
genauer an denn gerade hier könnten
efuels noch einen weiteren Vorteil haben
bei der Verbrennung von Kerosin
entstehen nicht nur CO2-Emissionen
sondern auch Ruß und Stickoxide
evuels verbrennen zwar insgesamt nicht
viel sauberer als fossile Kraftstoffe
aber die Partikelemissionen konnten
deutlich reduziert werden in Flughöhe
ausgestoßen tragen diese Partikel zur
Wolkenbildung bei und beeinflussen so
das Klima
negativen also nicht um völlig Klima
eutral zu fliegen aber e-kerosin könnte
zu einer Reduzierung der Emissionen und
der Wolkenbildung beitragen wenn sich
dieser Effekt in weiterer Forschung
bestätigt dann könnten hier besonders
punkten
[Musik]
okay fassen wir das alles mal zusammen
wir wollen efuels nicht verteufeln wir
brauchen Sie für einen möglichst
CO2-freien Luft und sehverkehr aber weil
grüner Strom ein knappes Gut ist müssen
wir genau abwägen wo diese Kraftstoffe
eingesetzt werden und an dieser Stelle
kommen wir nochmal zu der Umfrage vom
Anfang zurück hier wurde ja nach der
Bereitschaft gefragt efuels im eigenen
Auto einzusetzen aber dabei gab es
gleich mehrere Probleme erstens bei
dieser Frage wurden gar nicht alle aus
der Stichprobe befragt Menschen die kein
Auto oder nur ein E-Auto besitzen z.B
wurden nicht gefragt
zweitens nur 16 % der Befragten gaben an
genau zu wissen was die fuels überhaupt
sind danach gab es zwar eine kleine
Erklärung aber auch die nur sehr vage
und da wurde gesagt dass man annehmen
soll das
klimaneutral sind oder zumindest
hergestellt werden können und dass sie
nur wenig mehr kosten als normales
herkömmliches Benzin was aktuell nicht
der Fall ist diese ganze Studie ist also
relativ manipulativ und kommt
praktischerweise durch schlechtes
Studiendesign zu einem Ergebnis das
Mineralöl Unternehmen gefallen könnte
von einem Verband mittelständischer
mineralunternehmen
klar dass das Framing als klimaneutraler
Kraftstoff aus Luft und Wasser zieht
aber wir können uns nicht auf eine
Technologie verlassen die vielleicht
irgendwann in den Mengen funktioniert
die wir brauchen sicher man kann
bestimmt noch ein paar Prozent
Wirkungsgrad rausschlagen aber wo immer
es möglich ist ist der Antrieb über
Elektromotoren die deutlich effizientere
Lösung die Hoffnung auf e-fuels darf
kein weiter so bedeuten in diesem Sinne
bleibt neugierig euer Cedric